Twitter has been instrumental in
American politics and elections what
role do you think X will play in the uh
2024 us elections well our goal is to be
as even-handed and fair as possible you
know whether some is right left
independent whatever the case may be um
that um the platform is as fair and
and as much of a Level Playing Field as
possible and in the past Twitter has not
been um because Twitter was controlled
by Fall activists objectively they they
would describe themselves as that um so
um you know so so some people like well
has it moved to the right well it's
moved to the center so from the from the
perspective of the far left yes it is
move to the right because everything's
to the right from the far left um but no
one in the far left that I'm aware of
has been suspended or you know banned or
de Amplified um so you know but we're
trying to be inclusive for the whole
country and and for you you know for
other countries too um so there's a
diversity of viewpoints and Free Speech
only matters um if people you don't like
are allowed to say things you don't like
because uh if that's not the case you
don't have free speech and it's only a
matter of time before uh the censorship
just turned upon you do you think uh
Donald Trump will come back to the
platform he recently posted on Truth
social about this
podcast uh do you think truth social is
a funny name
you you know every time you post on true
social it's the truth yes well every
time like 100% it like like it's
impossible to
lie I just find it funny that every
single thing is a truth like 100% yeah
that seems unlikely I think gerdle will
say something about that there's some
mathematical contradictions possible if
everything's a Truth uh do you think
he'll come back to X and and start
posting there I mean
I think he owns a big part of Truth so
truth social to yeah truth social that
Tru the concept he owns truth hope you
bought it um so I think I think uh
Donald Trump I think he owns a a big
part of Truth social so um you know if
if if he does want to post on the X
platform we would allow that um you know
we we obviously must allow a
presidential candidate to post on our
platform Community notes might be really
fascinating there the interaction notes
is Awesome's let's hope it holds
up yeah again in in in the political
climate where it's so divisive and so in
so many intensely viral posts yes
Community notes it's like it seems like
a essential breath of fresh air yeah
it's great um in fact like the I no no
system is going to be perfect but the
the batting average of community notes
is incredibly good
I've I I actually frankly yet to see an
incorrect note that survived for more
than a few hours how do you explain why
it works yeah so the the the magic of
community notes is it requires people
who have historically disagreed in how
they've rated notes in order to um write
a note or rate you know and you have to
rate many notes M um and
so we could we actually do use AI here
so we populate a vector space around um
how somebody has has rated notes in the
past so it's not as simple as left or
right because there are many more life
is much more complex than left or right
um so there's a bunch of correlations in
how you would how you rate Community
notes posts um Community notes
so um then uh in order for a community
note to actually be shown um people who
historically have disagreed on a subject
must agree in order for a note to be
shown
um that's the essential magic of it I
mean but it's fascinating because
there's a there's a pool of people that
have disagreements and somehow they
collaborate through that process of
disagreement to come up with context for
I mean fascina it works yeah it it kind
of makes sense that that if people who
who in the past have disagreed agree
about something um it's probably
true yeah I wonder is there is there
possible somehow emergent thing there
that could challenge Wikipedia which
Wikipedia is a different kind of thing
which is more like permanent articles
about things but Wikipedia is very
hierarchical uh whereas um Community
notes is inherently not uh there is no
hierarchy like I the ASD test is um I
can't change a community note if some
put a gun to my
head
so um and and any CH and community
community notes uh has all the code is
open source 100% all the data is open
source 100% so you can completely
recreate any note in the system
independently um so if there was any
interference you'd notice
immediately